oh hi guys as a lot of you probably know
because I ranted on about it forever but
I have made my very first game on the
Play Store called sleep paralysis I made
this game with my game dev team if you
want to find out more about that there
are videos on that however I wanted to
do a little let's play of my mom playing
the game because it's like supposed to
be a sort of horror simulation
experience on the Google cardboard and a
my mom had never used the cardboard
before and B I just saw it be fun
because she's my mom she doesn't really
play games she doesn't do well with
horror at all I thought I'd share this
experience with you and show you a
little let's play walkthrough of my own
sleep paralysis with my mom so here is
my mom playing the game enjoy
[Music]
so I'll put a look for that all right
okay well you're just in the menu screen
so you can steal whatever you want but
each cloud has a different audio file on
it and if you move them close to you
which you can just do boy look here oh
it's supposed to represent dreams yeah
maybe press Start yeah it's so much
different doing it this way
it's very spooky for the light back on
again see that light doesn't stay on for
very long does it
some on the bookcase now when the circle
goes bigger does that mean there's
something gonna be yeah you need to look
at it for long yeah I want to keep it
light on
I can't wait to tell Alejo Oh
oh that's a Oh God oh oh oh God wait
[Music]
oh okay right nap on there what door my
body had door okay give me nightmares
you know
a few
teddy bear teddy bear go oh my god
oh wait I'm a taste-off the copilot city
there oh here we go
I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've forgotten how that was very good
very scary at the end yes
how did you find the game very
interesting very bit scary bit creepy
bit panicky when I couldn't find the
lights when obviously all right you just
say wake up wake up wake up and you hear
the waking up and you're trying to find
the lights that's a bit scary finding
everything is quite good but yeah you
want more I want more and I'll do
another one okay now as I said this game
was developed as a part of my University
course which I am now in third year and
it wasn't just me it with Tabitha and
Tiffany which are the girls that I work
with in University you want to find them
all there are videos on that so press
the little cards that I have put
throughout this video to find out more
about that and if you want to hear more
about my gamedev experience any
questions at all do put them in the
comments below my mum actually did miss
a couple of things in the game but
that's the whole point of a simulation
everyone has a different experience you
know so you can actually play it for
longer there are different things that
you can do we made this game in three
months however so not that many things
you can do but I'm still very very proud
of the way that it turned out and it's
pretty funny to see
freak out a little bit in virtual
reality so anyway if you want to give
the game ago the link will be in the
description below it is on the Google
Play Store for Android only I'm afraid
but who knows you might get to play
another game in the future that was made
partially by me because we are making
another game at the moment so yeah those
most probably anyway I hope you enjoyed
this and have lovely dairyman bye